okay good luck good luck you too
wait white moves first oh wait
it didn't start it
we may have broke the clock oh wow oh
bigger
that sounds like [ __ ]
we should do an intro though yeah i'm
here with the amazing
how do you pronounce your name dina last
name
do you know how is this announced in
russian i could try it bellankaya
bean and crab billing usually i
pronounce it in english like bellingtaia
okay yeah so we're gonna play a three
plus two game
um and i'm gonna beat you have we played
before
no i don't think so i don't think so
also
nemo welcome back if you want to join in
like offer some commentary
cool just did the commentary yeah just
well beating
eric
but i i i am responsible for that um
wait you didn't give me this option you
just made me play
your wife wait this clock is broken
here's your pond
oh my god how did you do that oh my god
did you guys see no what do you do i did
the magic trick oh
it's where i take the pawn i place it oh
my god
are you familiar with such a move i've
played this a few times
okay are you familiar with the staff or
gambit uh not really but here we go with
uh four knights and you don't three
nights
oh my pawns i'm taking it
oh my god what's that oh so you're not
familiar with the stafford gambit oh i
saw you from hahaha
well that doesn't sound fun i actually
have not watched the staff again
there's a rule in chess when you're up
material you should trade
okay then i will not oh this is a
solid solid defensive
let's see your point development first
so you are being impressed i just want
to be hyper hyper aggressive
okay whatever you wish for
i'll be solid my wish is your command
or wait is that the quote
your wish is my command or your command
is my wish
is your wish wait what no this is just
not correct this isn't now these are
crips
okay i just invented this bishop doesn't
want to be on d4
no it does not three plus two oh
you know that is a bad um it's a bad
hormone
bad um i want to say that
okay you actually it's your wish is my
command so whoever said that
you have to google that
we had the right words just the order
was off let's go here sounds like me
when i speak english
and now we push wow yeah i like dina's
playstyle
this is different from when you played
the blitz match against me yeah i'm
wondering what is my style
in fact there's a weird thing on a3
which yes let us put it away
this uh weird thing is called uh
initiative
and a phone up i'm trying to distract
you
i'm scared you see your knight you're
about to hurt me
and your other knight is attacked and
i'm pulling up
and plus i'm trust talking the more
pawns you're on the more open files i
have
are you actually attacking me i'm just
looking on the right side of life
wow you are fearless
you know there is no threat there right
my king is not on g-1 so you won't meet
me but how are you going to get
that's true i mean usually in the
opening you're supposed to castle
protect your king
now seems like a good time hmm how am i
going to castle i'll figure it out later
i'm down two pawns oh chester bonds
but i'm up to open files
let's see what you want in fact switch
ones
okay
do i get rid of this one
do you know what the rule says get rid
of what you can get rid of your queen
absolutely that's my wish
my wish is your command
but don't go um according to this oh
i'll grant you one wish
okay if i go here oh i see your point
they're being really oppressed you know
what
forget about everything we said i don't
want this night
and i do not want this one either
wow yeah that's the spirit
that's the russian chess school your
grandparents
should be familiar with this one great
friend
it's true i'm sorry for your parents i
think i have
russian blood i've never really went to
a russian school though
i'll just keep giving away material wow
this is a morphe chest school
wow there is more for american style
so i have two options
wow you are giving me everything you're
giving me a nice time advantage
it's just a time you know
yeah yeah yeah it's all right don't
worry
so um they say oops called bishops
are close to draw but i do not want to
draw
just kick away your most active fees and
then
uh life will be easier for me
24 seconds is nothing when you have two
seconds increments
are you feeling disturbed i'm disturbed
you didn't take my free night
no because you knew there was my queen
and i was worried for it
it's true but i'm still disturbed
yeah that's that's okay that's normal
incredible trade
good always good to trade that's the
peaceful approach
uh-huh i'm a peaceful person oh my god
that is
actually disturbing
i'm more worried about dina's time than
i am about a position
okay i think we're all disturbed here
it's true time is running
wow i see the
that's my point
i see my point
that's not the kind of position i i
wished for with all the material you
gave me on the way
i tried to grant you a wish but you
didn't take it
how did you say my wish is your wish my
wish
is your command my wish is your command
yes
my wish is your command my way your wish
is my
no your wish is my command yeah that
would make a lot more sense
i don't know what's more confusing this
position is figuring out the english
language
i'm actually gonna strike it of course
on english like
vocabulary because i want to come up
with more creative ways to like roast my
chats
oh that's the that's a very smart plan
especially after everything you've been
through here
they are going to roast you as much as
they can so um
you should prepare some backup plans
that's a big sacrifice
right everything's from the chit chat oh
my boy what is your
plan i don't know i don't see any idea
thank you for the bishop
no no no that's not how it works
i didn't know that's not how it works
don't get me dude what are you doing
there
he's taking your bishop what are you
doing there
oh my god oh my god what's that
you tell me ah i don't like it
just calculate if that's winning and
points i don't like it
no no no
thank you that was actually amazing that
was actually really nice
good game good game thank you that was a
that was a good fight
eric rose's tactic okay i mean you
should have been better there
yeah your trash talk was better though
you you yeah you were you went
on that front you were very vocal with
your words
so when i played queen a4 i guess me and
just when i played queen a4 instead of
taking my bishop
you should play b3 yeah take with b-pawn
and then i'm down a piece and pawns
and your king is safe yeah yes yes i got
greedy
i got greedy yeah i got reckless
but yeah it paid off